I have a lot simpler goal for this talk
which is to give you some understanding
some motivation for eth and strong eth
and i will have only few slides talking
about the consequences and they will be
elaborated upon during the rest of the
four days so that part will be it will
be minimal okay but before we get to
understanding the I to understand the
motivation for ETH I need to develop I
need to take you through through through
a quick trip of exponential time
algorithms for NP complete problems and
you have seen satisfiable two algorithms
this morning and I'm going to broaden it
little bit and sore is going to kind of
expand upon that and talk about the
details and bullet for will not be
talked about so that's that's so the
main I mean when we so okay
so that phenom okay so let me start with
a kind of observation Rando and we know
that all np-complete currents are
equivalent as far as polynomial time
reduce a polynomial tablet disabilities
are concerned so that means if one is
solvable in polynomial time than
everyone else is okay but on the other
hand if you focus on and if you don't
believe that P equals NP and and if you
see that as a remotest possibility so
then you would start wondering about
what is the exact complexity of NP
complete problems and then you start
noticing problems very wide links in
their complexity so before I go I let me
define what exact algorithm means it is
there a deterministic a randomized
algorithm that produces exact solutions
so that's so that's the definition and
we are focusing on the worst case
complexity so the post average case
complexity so those are the two two
stipulations so we could ask a similar
question as that are similar to the one
we asked for satisfiability what kind of
for improvements can we can we expect
over exhaustive search but one one
caution we have to take is that what
exactly is the complexity parameter here
in the case of satisfiability we kind of
implicitly are naturally assumed the
such spaces to to that actually that so
the search space is 2 to the N which is
the set of all possible assignments and
therefore we took n as the number of we
took n which is the number of variables
as the complexity parameter so then we
were looking for improvements over that
but but in general it will not be clear
what's the natural complexity parameter
so we are going to leverage that out and
we're going to define problems together
with the complexity parameters so then
talk about so talk about improvements
over so with respect to the complexity
parameter so one way to think of the
complexity parameter is that it could be
the size of the sedge space or the log
of the size of the search space and or
something else that that has a good
motivation
so if you can find improvements over
exhaustive search what limits what are
the obstructions to the improvement so
these are the basic question we see a
variety of complexities and so we want
to improve upon exhaust research and and
the and the last one is an ambitious
question what principle can will explain
the various complexities so can we come
up with a small set of principles that
will explain the exact complexities of
of most of the interesting problems so
these are the meta-level goals and so
let me go through the definitions so
problems come with two things would like
one is the size of instance and the
second one is the complexity parameter
and so for example case at formula you
have the formula size which is a number
of clauses or the number of literals and
the number of variables a one can take
number of variables so to be the
complexity parameter I've seen this case
it it measures the size of the search
space or one could also take the number
of clauses as the complexity parameter
it's whatever you want to take care of
complexity parameter so so basically
problems will come together with a
kilometer so that's the framework here
so for example for a Hamiltonian path
you take the number of vertices as a
complexity parameter or you can take the
log of the search space so you have n
factorial permutations of the path of
the repeal of the paths that encompass a
simple paths that encompass all vertices
you can take the log of that as you were
a parameter for some more examples you
can take the circuit SAT and and circuit
size is the size of the instance and the
number of variables are more generally
you can look at the class NP and you can
look at the number of the circuit size
as a parameter and and the number of
existential a quantified boolean
variables as your complexity parameter
so this is a fairly natural parameter so
that that measures the search spice that
measures the search space and moreover
with this parameter so you can reduce
every other problem a problem problem
NP work to the circuits are problem
without without increasing the parameter
size so once we have our parameters so
pretty previously way so we are focused
on preserving the size of the instance
within polynomial bounds okay now we are
also interested in preserving the
complexity parameter within some bounds
okay so circuit SAT is say I is a good
problem or or the mother of all problems
because it preserves the complexity
parameter so now we can define what we
mean by kind of improved kind of exact
algorithms over usage if n is the
parameter complexity parameter poly em
poly of the size of instance at times 2
to the N is the kind of exhaustive
search improve upon that so that's kind
of improved exact problem so this is so
mind that this is in so it's improvement
is with respect to the parameter so for
example that ok I'll give a number of
examples of improved exponential time
algorithms for aquifer NP complete
problems so so that's so three said
that's the best known constant and with
complexity parameter being n so that's
an improvement same thing for for set
and more generally for que cette we have
that kind of improvement so similarly 4k
color ability so we had improvement up
to three and four and and so an
exhaustive search where you take the
number of vertices as the complexity
so Hamiltonian path has a more
interesting historical or equally
interesting history compared to color
ability and 3 set and the first
algorithm which achieves the 22 then
bound can be viewed as an improvement
over the parameter log in factoria so
basically exhaustive search may require
you to go through all permutations and
the data on the very first anamika
algorithm or inclusion exclusion
algorithm can be viewed as a significant
improvement and and and even if you take
the number of vertices of the complexity
parameter so we are able to improve and
so that's the most recent result C prime
right so that's the state of the art for
for the Hamiltonian path problem okay to
give you some more examples okay
right
so if we take okay so this is an example
where we don't have it where we don't
have an improved algorithm when you take
the number of vertices of the complexity
of around the best algorithm we know is
true to their time and an exponential
space I'll get to that can little later
so let me skip independent set and so
and if you look at circuit SAT so there
are for the more general circuit set we
don't know of any other algorithms
better than 2 to the N and if you look
at special cases so we have a variety of
algorithms due to a variety of people
and I'm sure Ryan will talk about ACC
satisfiability subsequently and and we
also have improvements for depth to
thresholds that you satisfied so this is
just a quick rundown of a class of
algorithms for which we have improved
allegan for which you a class of
problems for which we have improved
algorithms so with respect to certain
parameters so that okay so this raises a
number of questions this is the starting
point for you ok 44 thinking about ETH
or or for motivating ETH okay so so
which problems have improved algorithms
for example that for example we know
that so we know that case enf has
improved algorithms when we take the
number of variables as a complexity
parameter but on the other hand if you
take CNF SAT we know of no improvements
similarly color ability of chromatic
number or the we we also the best we
know is 2 to the n algorithm and and
this is not an improvement when we take
the number of what is this is a
complexity parameter
when we have improvements can we expect
more and more improvements so three sad
people have tried for a long time try to
improve it and there have been a
sequence of improvements unfortunately
the progress stalled at a two to the
zero point three eight six times N and
so can we expect to improve it and if
not why not and the same thing for three
color operating so there have been a
series of improvements and the progress
has stalled so if we can't improve it
can we prove that improvements for
preset beyond a certain point or not
possible or subject to a certain
complexed assumptions so we don't know
how to do that either and and and
perhaps we can can aim lower and and can
we connect can we connect the progress
on various problems together improvement
on a continued improvement and 3sat and
continued improvement on a three-color
ability may be related if we can
establish that that begins that could
begin a complexity theory of exact
algorithms and that's so that's the
starting point for this thing yes
ideally you would like to cancel the
first questions the first question and
oh and so we will settle for the last
question and try to see whether there
are connections
so one thing I do want to say is a lot
of effort has gone into these algorithms
so we'll explain it further and a
variety of techniques have been used and
this is a kind of productive area so new
techniques have been developed and our
different or clever analysis have been
developed and so this led to so this is
a maybe 15 years of work led to several
text books and and that's a good thing
so so what we are focusing on is that
can we find some principles that govern
these complexities and and so we will
focus on the the simplest of these
questions can we connect various
complexities so for example 3 color
ability versus 3sat so for example if
three color bility has a sub exponential
time algorithm by that I mean to to the
epsilon and algorithm where epsilon can
be made arbitrarily is smaller that it
does it imply a sub exponential time
algorithm for 3sat so this is a concrete
question to motivate to motivate the ETH
and specification
so what's the obstacle in proving such a
result so you can take the standard
reduction reducing priests add 23 color
ability take the standard reduction so
this is how the reduction works so you
you take a three set on n variables with
about n cubed classes or with em clauses
and you reduce it to a graph with n plus
M vertices and about n plus M edges
if we take the number of variables on
the number of vertices as the complexity
parameter respectively so the complexity
parameter is blown up after a man it
becomes n cube roughly and since we did
not drill the complexity parameter so
even if three-color ability is solvable
2 to the X 1 and time for arbitral small
epsilon that would not translate into a
similar algorithm for three side so
we're kind of stuck here so
so it
so let me talk about the most important
tool or the most the tool we found most
useful to to lift us out of this diorama
I know and that the tool comes in the
form of this Parsifal Emma and their two
concepts that are important and oh and
oh and one of the myths of exponential
time reduction but but let me restate it
let me allure is the same lemmas as this
morning and in sub exponential time for
any given epsilon in 2 to the epsilon
and time we can rewrite kc NFL with an
arbitrary k CNF as as a disjunction of
linear size k CM s such that the
solution space is preserved and and
that's the strongest statement you can
make and so let me show you how with
this with this lemma that we could we
could lift ourselves out of the
obstruction we faced early so let's
continue with the same proof okay let's
go let us look at the reduction from
3sat 23 color ability and we want to
preserve the linearity in the parameter
value so why is that so we so the proof
okay the proof we want to so the
argument we want to make is that if
three color Allah tea with number of
vertices as a complexity parameter is
solvable sub exponential time so we
would like to conclude 3sat with the
number of variables as a complexity
parameter is also solvable in sub
exponential and such a conclusion would
be possible if we can do a reduction
from 3sat to three color ability where
there where the complexity parameter is
maintained where the complexity program
which is a treasure would linearly so
now you see that is possible so we start
with the three CNF we apply
specification lemma so which was an
epsilon we apply specification llama now
we have 2 to the epsilon and sub
instances for each instance and each
three CNF instance has a soul in ear
size now we take that linear size 3 CNF
and convert that into egg I reduce it in
a graph with linearly many vertices and
linearly many edges such that the three
CNF is is satisfiable if and only if the
corresponding graph is three color same
standard reduction but we restricted to
sparse k cnips or spot three CMS and so
we preserve the linearity of the
parameter and 0 and so therefore now we
can conclude that a sub exponential time
algorithm for three color ability
implies one for treason
so that's where the kind of
specification Lamar kind occupies a
central place in making these parameter
preserving or linearity preserving
reductions and so if you think about it
I'm not going to go into the
specification ulema proof and you so
that the the two key things that work is
of course apart from a clever argument
some exponential time reductions and and
so that's the key to our key flexibility
we have we can spend it s of exponential
amount of time so so the lemma itself
comes from a branching program so you
branch and clauses and try to balance
both sides and so try to try to control
for the number of leaves you get in this
process and and without branching too
much so you can get your linear size
formulas so then you are happy so that's
that's very high level
okay so we are able to connect to
canonical NP complete problems the
progress with respect to kind of
improved exponential time algorithms in
the natural complexity parameters so it
turns out this this this is a key for a
much larger class of results and and and
let's take a subclass of NP complete
problems called S&P I'm not going to I
will so the definition is whatever it is
so you have a second-order quantified
existence will quantify followed by a
first-order you for sure the universal
quantifiers this subclass includes
problems like k sath and Kay color
ability and so that's an example of how
you could express k sat in that model
and i underst and it also includes
problems like vertex cover click
independent set and k said cover in the
so-called size constrained S&P so we
kind of we restrict the size of the
solution and oh and oh and so and
problems like Hamiltonian path RS
np-hard so the main point is that so far
this subclass of NP complete problems so
they're so they're naturally reducible
to k sath so therefore if you understand
case hat so we can now deal with all the
class of problems okay so
so this is the main result and oh and
are now so 3sat admits a sub exponential
time algorithm we found only with one of
the problems in SMP admits one so we
connected a whole bunch of problems
together so that so the possibility of
sub exponential time algorithm see is
kind of intimately linked so they're all
linked together go back in time where I
guess yeah I cannot go back in time so
intervene over complexities of the time
I think that's when I started
programming okay so let me give a sketch
of the proof and oh and and so basically
every problem in this class is reducible
to case hat okay and and we are going to
show that ok specification ulemas allows
k sath can be reduced so k sad can be
reduced to three sad while preserving
their complexity parameter so let me
spend a minute are talking about the
standard reduction that we use from k
sath oh okay from for set 2 3 set for
example so you have closets with for up
with four literals so you want to take
such a formula and reduce it to a
formula with with with only three
literals per class so the typical thing
is that you will introduce additional
variables so rewrite the class as a
conjunction of or so of chartres size
clauses the number of clauses you
introduce okay the number of new
variables introduced is proportional to
the number of clauses for each for class
you may have to introduce one or two new
variables is one yeah and and if you
have and if you have n to the for many
variables in a force CNF that requires
you to introduce into the for many new
variables to reduce it to a2 a3 sienna
so doing so you are not so you're not
preserving the complexity parameter
linearly so therefore you cannot draw
useful conclusions but on the other hand
with the specification lemma you can
take a case enf and your sub exponential
time you can reduce it to a linear size
K CNF then reduce it to a3c enough by
introducing new variables but but only
linearly many new variables and so
therefore while preserving the parameter
which is the number of variables so we
are able to go from an arbitrary problem
in SNP 23 sat once again specification
my sake and so that shows if 3sat can be
solvable in sub exponential time so then
the whole class is some okay so that's
so that's basically there okay so that
gives you some motivation to make a
hypothesis and and of course we don't
have a 3sat is solvable in sub
exponential time or not I don't think
Russell I neither resin that I have a
bet on that and and we thought it's
useful to have to come up with a
hypothesis and can bifurcate the world
into two words are still like so many
more words but we have a world so we are
going to so let me introduce one
notation which would be useful down the
road and for each for each case at for
each K so let us introduce a constant
I'll let us introduce a number called S
sub K which is the best constant for
solving case hat so using an exact
algorithm which could be randomized so
let's a las vegas type out
so eth basically is that that s 3 is
bounded away from 0 so that's a so
that's exponential time hypothesis and
and so so subject to this hypothesis
every problem in s and P are no problem
in S&P has a sub exponential time
algorithm it's just picked to the
natural complexity parameter which is
the size of the size of the second order
yeah right so but what what class is
that precisely so these are the NP
complete
I think SNP itself is defined a subset
of NP complete problem no no sorry
np-hard problems also SNP hard maybe so
if you assume so the standard proof of
the dichotomy theorem then every
constraint satisfaction problem is that
that's not in polynomial time is
np-complete under gadget reductions and
for every one of those problems thats
np-complete under gadget reductions you
can show that it's in sub exponential
time if and only if Reese three sets of
its of exponential time so in that sense
every and basically every np-complete
problem that you know of in snd is
complete under gadget reductions and the
conjecture is that all of them are so
pretty much every problem that that you
can think of is equivalent to three set
for having some
okay so
so 11 my kind of one small perspective
is the following thing right now so we
know very little about exponential time
algorithms in this sense i was so I we
know very little about nonlinear time
what we can do in nonlinear time so so
proving law approving time lower bounds
has evaded oh now has a food to be
looser okay so one so one way to judge
the value of e th is that can we take
this principle can we take this
hypothesis and try to explain the
complexities try to prove our bonds that
match the best known bounds so that
might serve as a that might serve as a
justification for ETH or the value of
the ETH and subject to this hypothesis
at least we can explain the known
complexities so and maybe maybe that's
how we can judge any of the Prince egg
because any of the hypothesis we make
and and so the thing is that so so it
does ETH factor out the essential
difficulty of dealing with exponential
time algorithms perhaps not and it only
deals with one aspect of the exponential
time algorithms I thought I have s'more
principles are needed so to understand
the set of X the set of exponential time
algorithms for NP complete problems so
so this is one principle that that
proved to be useful so that's my high
level perspective about so this kind of
invites maybe we need more so so so you
know if we can't understand time so we
can try to figure out what are the right
principles we can use to explain the
rest of the principle that I have to
explain the rest of the facts and it's
not clear what those principles are and
they need to have a lot of expletive al
you to be useful
and functional Russell will talk about
non-deterministic strong eth in that in
this week
okay um so let me quickly go through a
couple of slides of some of the
consequences so so there is a nice
survey paper bye bye Daniel and Daniel
and socket and and
so so let's look at special cases for
planar graphs we know that to to the big
o of square root and algorithms exist
and and the car et al remove the
possibility of two to the little o of
square root and algorithms and for fpt
problems these also rules or the
possibility of two to the little o of K
times poly type algorithms for many
problems and W and complete problems it
can eliminate the possibility of end to
the little o of k type algorithms for a
clicker independent set so so the best
known algorithms of the forms will have
the form F of K times n to the K and I
can eat eh are you rules or the
possibility of n to the little o of K
algorithms
similarly for dominating set and
problems that are parameters by three
week so Daniel will go into the Daniel
box will go in detail into these things
I'm just flashing the results and
so so basically for many interesting
problems sub exponential time algorithms
have been ruled out so using ETH so
that's the kind of high-level summary
and Daniel will talk about some of the
reductions and okay so one thing you
notice with ETH is that we don't have
any so the kind of results are the kind
of lower bounds are of the type to to
the little o of n 2 to the little square
root n R 2 to the little o of K we are
not able to show that you need two to
the K times poly n about a particular
problem and you can prove precise
exponents because our assumption ETH
itself is not precise enough it simply
says that s 3 is bounded away from 0 and
we don't know what that constant is even
with respect to that constant can we
prove some lower bounds and it's also
not clear and how to do that so and we
went in a different route and and and
improved as somewhat different results
so we're so let me kind of focus on one
of the interesting lower bounds we
obtained by using ETH this has to do
with the complexity of the case enf as K
increases i define this constant s sub K
which is that which is the best exponent
for the complexity of k sath and so what
can we say about this sequence of
constants assuming ETH so what we show
is that it is increasing infinitely
often so this sequence
so and and I let us define the limit of
this sequence to be to be says infinity
and so we not only and we also show that
the gap between the limit and their sub
K is at least do okay for some absolute
constant so we have some idea about how
it is increasing under and and so
basically assuming ETH we can kind of
say why why the heuristics for that work
for 3 CN a 3sat may not work that well
for case had become complexity has to so
necessarily increase and of course
assuming ETH so here we take the leap
okay so let me give a proof of this
result random and kind of how do you
show that that the complexity or the
constants S sub K are increasing
infinitely often so the idea is the kind
of self reduction and so we could we
take a case enf and we do and using sub
exponential time we reduce it to k prime
CNF k prime is much larger than K and
and of course it's a touring reduction
and while doing that reduction we are
going to have that we are going to
exhibit an interesting trade-off between
the class width and the number of
variables so k prime is much larger than
K so so we have more expressive power so
we want to exploit that expressive power
and I didn't I kind of in that trade we
would like to reduce the number of
variables so to go back to so let's a
five-minute assume that you so the case
that has at most one solution so we
already show that in the this morning
that roughly an hour k variables are
forced
and maybe we can eliminate those
variables as a consequence on knowing
the other variables so those variables
can be functions of the other variables
can we use the expressive power of this
so the so these larger with the clauses
to eliminate those k variables so then
we can achieve the trailer so reduce the
number of variables and increase the
width so then we are getting so then we
get a connection between s sub k & S sub
K Prime and that is the so that's the
game plan and oh so that's so that's
basically the proof sketch okay so
certain variables are forced I know and
which variables are forced can be can be
guests or can be determined by looking
at locally okay but to be able to do
that one need to have the locality and
that requires pacification the
specification guarantee is no variable
occurs in more than K to the K many
closets so the influence of the
variables is somewhat limited and we can
and we can take advantage of that are to
express this dependency so using larger
closet okay specification lemma is
crucial for this result and so we can
establish so using a variety of
techniques we can establish that this
constant keep increasing
we have any information that says that
the constants increase somewhat quickly
to test some infinities some thing in
the end the opposite direction of this
like is doing beautiful you know lower
bound on the rate of convergence to the
limit it follows from the gap is the
deal what case so if you know he's
asking how what's the smallest cell so
that we know the SL is bigger than SK
and we compute that L but on the actual
limit constant ok that's it what s
infinity really is and and then we have
to use sparse vacation with the epsilon
and the smarts vacation less than not
like the constant ok prime is at least K
to the K our larger water of
exponentially something like change to
the K okay hello but what I was actually
asking is like suppose that you know s
infinity is point one and we want we
want 2k large enough so that it's you
know so that s sub K is within epsilon
of point one for that
that should give you a gap between the
two things the other way so that i don't
think we know oh yeah eek wanted no yeah
and in fact that would be really
interesting is if we could show he can't
converge to us infinity faster since
that would say for example if strong eth
is true if you hadn't interaction the
other way that every algorithm then you
can't have an algorithm that's of a
different form than of order 1 and k
savings and we don't know that the
technique for showing for CNF for CNF to
reduce for CNF 23 C&F introduces far too
many variables it's not clear what the
trade-off is so we'd like to introduce
few more variables so you want to do
that trade-off in the reverse direction
so let's say i want to go from four CNF
23 CNF soyuz so let's say one in came
all variables can you can you shrink the
closet and we don't know how to do that
that will give a kind of nice resultant
so let me skip over this one
so so we know that the sequence is
infinitely increasing and I know so so
thanks to ryan we know that who tried
very hard to come up with a faster
satisfied algorithm for c and have sad
so we got the courage to make it to take
a leap and say that this limit is 1 so
there are two pieces of evidence one is
that if you look at the best satisfiable
Duggan's for k sath so they so so they
behave like one minus one over K so that
dependence on k seems to be there if if
we go in the limit the limit constant is
one but independent of that right so
this is so this is not a rational
justification so this is a this is a
kind of justification where we made the
leap to believe that as infinite equals
one we also assume that I mean this we
also assume they're exponential time
hypothesis was right like we have to
assume SF 3 is greater than zero and
because if it is implies that this
implies their strong eth imply see th
you can go from kc n f 2 so 3 CNF see if
the limit is 1 for some concrete k so it
is at least 0.9 from that you can go to
3c and reduce it to three CNF and so
then you know that s 3 must be so this
is a stronger hypothesis strictly
stronger hypothesis and we don't know
how okay of course an interesting
question is that can we prove this using
ETH that would be that will reduce the
number of hypotheses required and that's
a good thing definitely good thing and
that will be so so so that will be a
tremendous result and and we all should
look forward to that to them so this
kind of explains that we don't
understand exponential time and we need
more principles and and so this is this
kind of came naturally this is an
adjacent one and
okay so right so let me give a kind of
different kind of evidence that and it
turns out that the best constants for a
okay for a variety of problems are
related as well so the vaporware where
we look at a number of natural problems
like a case at k hitting set k said
splitting and so on so either they all
have the constant so there so they have
their best car so the limit constant as
one or strictly less than 1 so it cannot
be that the limit constant of care
hitting set is less than 1 and the limit
constant of k sath is ok so that is
equal to 1 so this is some more indirect
evidence that that that the fate of all
these constants as far as being equal to
one is linked together so there are less
than 1 or it or they're all equal to 1
okay so let's let me give you a few
results quickly that follow from strong
eth there are many more results and so
you will see so you notice the precision
that we were able to achieve in terms of
lower bounds so for example for in de
pere for her independent set parameters
by tree width so the result to that you
need so true to the tree with rather
than to to the little o of three bit so
so dominating set parameters by so tree
with again requested a three to the
three width so we're able to obtain
precise constance an exponent subject to
strong eth so Daniel marks will say a
lot more about it and and so let me say
Virginia is going to have a full series
of lectures on this topic I'll just will
mention a few things that were my slide
before so it also says of a strong eth
not so surprisingly seem to say
something about the complexity of
problems in p so one problem is
orthogonal vectors so you have a bunch
of vectors of 0 1 vectors so over
integers let us say so you want to check
whether there are two of them that are
that are orthogonal to each other and
the Williams has shown that that cannot
be solved in strictly sub quadratic time
so unless strong eth is false recently
we have a similar flavor problem so you
have a bunch of real vectors you want to
know whether there exists a pair of them
such that one dominates the other
component wise so this again cannot be
solved in a work for sufficiently large
dimension for when the dimension of the
vector is omega of log in and where n is
the number of vectors
and so this is the only last result i
have mentioned and I call I have shown
that fresher distance which is a problem
that requires dynamic programming so I
typically use a dynamic programming
technique to solve it seem to require
strongly quad subtle or strong eth rules
out strongly is a quadratic algorithm so
many others and and Virginia will will
give a full kind of full version of this
slide I and many more things so let me
skip over all these things and
okay so let me mention somewhere some
open problems of course before that how
to say that these seem like hard
problems but on the other hand not many
people have thought about them it's
possible that they have easy solutions
are somewhat easier solutions and
assuming ETH can we prove a specific
bound on s3 or assuming ETH can be
proved as infinity equals 1 so there's
two questions I mentioned okay and so so
this one is an interesting question okay
so you have strong eth let us assume
that and that tells us something about
the complexity of CNF SAT or the limit
constant of the case E and F for a case
add exponents okay can can we say
something about the color ability does
it require 2 to the N time so it does
improving one help improving the other
or can we rule out a reduction between
the two types of problems so the best
known algorithms for a case at seem to
seem to use a branching style of
branching style techniques and whereas
wear a collar ability simply require
inclusion-exclusion principle it may be
there no reduction between these
problems that preserve the exponent
so so that seemed to so showing
something like showing the impossible
definite action so that will be
definitely interesting or there is a
direction between these two problems so
that will be great to know so then we
can reduce the number of principles we
need to understand in the color ability
problem let's skip that one let's skip
that one too so these are part of the
talk i skipped but so the first two are
should make like we should be able to
make a lot of progress if we could say
something about the foster questions
so there was a tradition in the crypto
program to offer monetary small monetary
awards on the scale like the rich prizes
for your open problems so which ones how
much money would you be willing to pay
for these new proving proving that s
infinity equals one could assuming ETH I
would put a high dollar value on that
500 this this is my eye is not about
money so they say about my judgment
about the difficulty of reasoning about
time now we have the normalizing
so for the second one are at least
correcting strung a connecting CNF SAT
and color ability I don't know I will
not place more than fifty dollars so you
in ruling out the possibility of such a
reduction both are equally interesting I
know I know and I mean one dream here is
that somehow can we classify the can we
classify the NP complete problems kind
of in a more fine-grain fashion so these
are the problems that require d PLL
style algorithms and to obtain the
optimal algorithms of course subject
assumptions these are the ones that
require inclusion exclusion and
reductions among them are not possible
under reasonable assumptions that kind
of classified stratifies the space of
for these problems and oh and that's
definitely progress if you can do that
and the same thing applies for quadratic
or cubic complexity problems
sedan you are you think hi pot so so you
eth us easy you know the SMP or some SNP
is there any any kind of rule of thumb
for understanding any other larger part
of the space there were a lot of apt
type consequences of some of these
assumptions but what do we know sort of
more broadly there there any sort of
water classifications so you are looking
for a larger class of problems by which
we could die then th you know and how do
we how do we judge a problem to suggest
whether it's going to be you know okay
that's how that's the kind of question
here in essence so let's say we have
strong or four ETH we have SNP can we
find their natural class for strong eth
that seems like seems like a good
question to start thinking about I
so it gets old enough for a little
different poll question so come fast is
hard for smt right which one they
haven't talked about yeah we suggest
someone in the mind you have some kind
of slices of these problems of hard area
in this context so what would be
possible for you know the harvester disk
are examples
so there is for a while I thought
Hamiltonian path is such a problem until
our Swedish colleagues demolished that
and i still believe it is hard for this
OPP model but I did think about the band
width problem for a while I know that
others are thinking about it I don't
even remember the definition I one or
anyone so that may be one such problem
that that may that that is np-hard and
and even other than Hamiltonian path
thank you so are there like natural NP
complete problems where the best
algorithm is 2 to the N squared time or
anything where the power bigger than 1
so this band which problem I believe in
to the end so that's what I'm shooting
for ending so of course in the natural
parameter is there I mean there are
artificial problems you can you can cook
up even then it is difficult
maybe pitch colorings of food example if
you parameterize by the number of
bureaucracies for what's the best known
algorithm for that it's okay you can
squeeze that down a little bit so it is
not presented okay so that seems like a
good problem
I'm not sure if I right so you gave some
examples of implications in parameterize
complexity and I deduce from that depth
or anything like that
okay I teach you this if W want to sort
of like ETH mw2 is like strongly
encouraged I mean there are dominating
your ways to form this one so engaging
with lies that PT is not spare w 1 and
this Eph implies that no not exactly not
exactly just said it's just like
weighted CNF SAT like having this
texture fan and ethic or at the bottom
is sort of what characterizes let me
meet you there are like formal theorem
showing and I have some organism like
they are between say e th and ftp versus
w1 but there's definitely analogues you
can take like results we're relating w
wine deviation just get results like
Madonna except for that one really that
you want to see anything but in terms of
Pacific Francis is the only
eh implies you to unfollow well there is
this result that he mentioned that if
you can solve k dominating set W to
complete problems just even a tiny bit
faster than n to the K then ETH is fall
sorry strong eth pistols so there's that
okay yeah there's no yeah it's not as
well developed any everyone card
but yes so he achieved I got that PP not
that you won but also meet adjusters
equal that myself I thought what is not
in terms of the glass feel bad for
specific program
thanks again